buenos días Así es el octavo paquete de
sanciones ya has aprobado por Los
Embajadores de la Unión Europea aunque
se debe ratificar de forma formal pero
ya está hecho es se produce una semana
después de que se propusiera este octavo
paquete de sanciones justamente en
respuesta a esta anexión de los cuatro
territorios del este de Ucrania uno de
los puntos principales es este límite al
precio del petróleo ruso que consiste en
que las empresas transportistas europeas
solo podrán llevar a petróleo y sus
derivados desde Rusia hasta a otra parte
del mundo siempre y cuando este se haya
vendido a un precio límite impuesto por
la Unión Europea y por los países del g7
con el objetivo de que Rusia reduzca sus
ingresos con la compraventa de petróleo
Eso sí después de armas negociaciones
entre los países de la Unión Europea
finalmente este límite solo se aplicará
si se suman otros es algo sería clave
por ejemplo que se sumara India porque
Grecia chipre y Malta tienen
preocupaciones de que esto podría
afectar a sus empresas navieras y que
podrían reducirse su cuota de Mercado
frente a los competidores en este
paquete de sanciones también se incluye
la prohibición de que ciudadanos
europeos puedan formar parte de los
consejos de administración de empresas
rusas y así evitar casos tan llamativos
como el del ex canciller alemán Gerard
roda que estuve durante años
participando en el consejo de
administración de la empresa gasística
gasprom también se amplía la lista de
personas sancionadas ya van cerca de
2.000 personas y esta vez en este
paquete se incluye el de Alexander uno
de los máximos ideólogos del
nacionalismo ruso del que se inspira
Vladimir Putin y cuya hija fue asesinada
en un atentado terrorista el pasado
verano finalmente También en esta nueva
lista de sanciones también se veta la
exportación de productos clave
tecnológicos para ejemplo para los
aviones pero también otras partes claves
de la tecnología muy importantes para la
industria de Rusia